lately I've been pushing the idea of
incidental training the idea is that you
perform exercises wherever you are
whatever you're doing that might mean
that you make a movement more difficult
by pistol squatting down to the ground
to pick something up instead of bending
over or it might mean that you just do
five pull-ups when you're walking
through any doorway and thereby use
greasing the groove to improve your
pull-up technique and your max count you
can stretch whilst watching TV you can
do curls off the kettle's boiling and by
constantly moving your body like this
like an animal you'll build far more
strength far more endurance and feel
better than ever most of us know this
intuitively or we at least know that we
should train more so why don't we
exercise as much as we know we should
the problem is for lot of us that we
just lack invigoration we just feel
tired we feel exhausted all the time if
I told you right now that I wanted you
to go and do some spider-man crawls in
the garden outside just 20 then maybe
the very thought of that would make your
toes curl you might feel weak you might
feel off balance you might feel too
tired what's the reason for this well I
assumed that it had to do with just
being overtired or overstressed but I
did some research and actually the
studies tend to show that being tired is
in sleep deprived doesn't make us any
physically weaker it only slightly hurts
our endurance and this comes down water
psychological factors such as motivation
so if being tired doesn't make you
weaker then why do you feel stiff and
achy and lethargic whenever you think of
working out why do you have to G
yourself up to one big workout why does
it take ages to rev yourself up to it
like a cold engine the reason is just
that you are like a cold engine you're
not exercising enough through the day
you're not even moving enough through
the day if you spend all day sitting at
a desk sitting on the sofa standing at
the kitchen you're barely moving your
body and what happens is you actually
lose that connection to the muscles they
build up a kind of residual tension more
tonus than is needed to just maintain
your posture this is made worse by
psychological stress which most of us go
through in droves each day and by the
fact that we're just so out of practice
eventually this lack of movement can
lead to a complete loss of awareness of
specific muscle groups leading to
awkward patterns of activation that
cause tightness poor movement patterns
and discomfort this can be both acute or
chronic
the latter is sometimes referred to as
sensory motor amnesia which is a term
coined by Thomas Hannah creator of
cymatics warming up was a nice idea in
theory is something that no animal in
the
or kingdom ever does you never see a dog
limber up before it chases prey if it
had to the prey would get away if you
think about any animal if you have a pet
then you'll notice that when they wake
up in the morning the first thing they
do isn't to bend over and touch their
toes and hold it for two minutes no
animal in the animal kingdom does that
instead they stretch out their spine
just for a couple of seconds you see
them reach up to the sky like they're
doing yoga and then get on with their
day they're not actually stretching here
what they're actually doing is something
called panda chelation panda q Latian is
slightly different from a stretch in a
stretch you move the limb or the body
part outside of your normal range of
motion that causes a contraction in the
muscle a stretch reflex and you have to
try and resist this in order to increase
your mobility this does nothing to
relieve tension has nothing to do with
your figuration on the other hand panda
chelation means that you're tensing the
muscle and then lengthening it and then
releasing it this is what happens when
you yawn or you stretch when you yawn
that's actually appendicular of the
respiratory muscles and what's happening
is that you're contracting and
lengthening your jaw muscles your neck
muscles and even your intercostal
muscles this is a kind of stretch but it
has a different purpose the idea here is
to remind to fire up that part of the
motor cortex to remind it where that
muscle group is to give it more control
over it to prime it ready for movement
and at the same time to listen to the
feedback from the muscle through gain
that sensory input because your muscles
remember our sensory organs they provide
us with proprioceptive your muscle
spindles and your Goldie tendon organ
our body uses these to know where it is
in space to know how tense you are to
know your position your posture to
create that mental map of your body so
like I say when you don't use the muscle
all day you actually forget how to use
it and at the same time you actually get
a buildup of tension which makes it much
harder to activate in future you feel
stiff you feel tense you feel tired and
when you think about moving you feel
wobbly and offset and jittery by
performing these pandit collations what
you're doing is reminding your body
where the muscle is and also releasing
that tension by consciously relaxing the
muscle so don't just yawn yawn with your
whole body stretch out your toes in the
morning stretch out your arms stretch
out your chest push your chest together
just contract and stretch if you
struggle to visualize what this should
be like then try yawning at the same
time you'll get more of an idea it
should feel good it shouldn't feel like
an amazing release so next time you're
thinking ma'am I could do 10 push-ups
now
don't have that energy or that sense of
control do something dick ulation for
your chest for your shoulders for your
legs stretch yourself out yawn suddenly
you might feel that you have the in
figuration you need to go ahead and do
it this is also fantastic before bed
because it helps to relax your muscles
you'll sleep far better once again just
like your dog or cat which never seems
to have any trouble waking up in the
night to go to the toilet and perhaps
the best part of all is that if you do
this regularly throughout the day and
make it habit then you'll eventually
start to improve your proprioceptive
because you're doing all the time on a
habitual basis you gain permanent
greater control over that muscle and
permanent greater connection to the
sensory information coming in you'll
gain that childlike movements that they
teach in Shaolin you'll be ready like a
coiled spring to launch into action at
any time and you don't have to stretch
and touch your toes for even a second
the other key is to keep moving
throughout the day don't spend 23 hours
sitting completely still and one hour
working out to the gym the aim here is
not to do loads of workouts throughout
the day and intensive ly push yourself
with no chance of recovery
instead we're simply moving the muscles
to remember they're there to cement new
skills and possibly even to slightly
improve muscle protein synthesis the
world around us has been designed to
make movement unnecessary everything is
at the right height for us many tasks
can be completed while sitting we need
to move in spite of this back and
thereby keep our bodies limber fired up
and ready to go whenever we need them
basically this becomes a virtuous cycle
you're probably just out of the habit of
moving but the more you move the easier
it becomes to exercise when you want to
actually have a workout and that in turn
means you're more likely to workout
which makes it easier to move whenever
you want to so give it a go let me know
what you think if this is something you
do already then comment down below and
let me know if it's worked for you and I
look forward to reading your comments
hope you enjoyed this quick little tip
stay tuned for more like this and much
bigger videos on the way soon subscribe
as well of course if you want to get
more and check out the links in the
description down below for my ebook and
program as well as the website the
Pioneer thanks a ton for watching and
bye for now